welcome to a new project camp update so
we bought this piece of land and are
prototyping a more sustainable way of
living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous update you've
seen matia dropping his van on the land
and today i'm actually going to give you
an update on the container
but for that we have to drive a little
bit
so today the containers arrived in
portugal
into a local place where you're going to
unload them because the well
the main truck from the highway which is
this one it doesn't
really go on to our land because it's a
bit too rough so we need to unload it
here and then a local guy with a crane
is going to put them on the left
so they're gonna use two of those to
lift them out
[Music]
okay
quickly
he's doing a wheelie my portuguese is
not so good yet but
i don't know where this is going they
look a bit doubtful
we'll see
plan a didn't work so now we have plan b
which is a
bigger forklift
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
yes
[Music]
then one
[Music]
oh
all right
right
[Applause]
the business of the classics are very
[Applause]
bad
[Applause]
oh
all right so the containers are
offloaded from the big
truck with the forklift
they were lifted off so now one is here
and over there and now we're going to
use this little local truck to drive it
to the land
because it can maneuver to the little
roads that we have there
so yeah almost there i think this was a
challenging part but we got it
hopefully the next is easier so next up
would be that the municipality will
clean the road
because it's hard to ride them with a
truck you might have seen in the
update number two where i talk about the
erosion of the roads so it makes this
really big holes in here
[Applause]
but also all the bushes that start to
overhang and broken trees
and it's a responsibility of the
municipality to keep the roads clean
so the moment we came we started asking
them to clean the
roads and but this is all actually in
portuguese
they don't speak english so for that we
have rita helping out
so could you describe a bit how it is so
far and where we're at with the roots
yes so it has involved a lot of
phone calls with presidents from
municipalities and presidents from
i don't know you call them
so the smallest municipality and the
biggest
municipality it has involved a lot of
um back and forth somehow
and um not too easy
sometimes to get to the people because
you only speak first to the secretaries
and then
the secretaries will say they will give
the information to the president
and then i call again and then they ask
what is it about again
and then we repeat this process again
and again and again
so so far we don't really know how is it
going
people don't really say if they will do
it or not
but when we try to ask for professionals
maybe that they do it
and that we don't have to wait for the
municipality
they say um that is responsibility of
the municipality
so we are a bit in a limbo right now so
what is
you think is like a weird question to uh
do the roads or they never do this or is
it the common thing
why do you think it takes so long i
don't know exactly why it takes so long
so how long are we now waiting for the
municipality to do this
um could be probably good two months
waiting for it can you still have hopes
never lose the hope
maybe i cut it that never yes
and because they keep saying something
like ah next week or
we'll we'll keep you updated soon and
stuff
how is that i think i've been worried
this is the portuguese mentality of
working
is it i mean you're a portuguese person
is it you like it or not or after
um yeah i myself don't know exactly how
it works
i would say next week it's a way
an expression of saying yes it will
happen
it gives you a hope that it will be
rather soon
and it never really happens
so so the containers might be arriving
at the land next week
that's a good way of putting it maybe
yes
yeah so that's basically the thing we
just need to wait for these roads to be
cleaned and then the containers can come
we've been waiting for a few weeks but
now the containers are in portugal
so hopefully it's going to be soon
because then we have containers on the
land
alright so that was this update we just
have to wait from now on
if you want to help us out financially
so we can bribe the municipality to make
this road faster
make sure to visit
support.projectcomp.com
if you like the project i want to see
the previous updates we did so far make
sure to go here
and if you want to see all the updates
that are still coming make sure to
subscribe we still have quite a few
updates coming
well for now thanks for watching and see
you in the next video